College
costs a fortune.
Most Americans can't afford tuition.
Fortunately
some colleges
now put their professors lectures
online
so
everyone can learn.
Here's a sample
How we derive energy
from triglyceride
This Berkeley video
makes chemistry interesting.
because carbon and hydrogen are nonpolar
those are insoluble
For five years
anyone could access
20,000 videos
on Berkeley's website.
But then
President Obama's Justice Department
sent Berkeley this threatening letter
Berkeley's in violation of title 2
The Attorney General may initiate a lawsuit.
It's all because of a well intended law
called
the Americans with Disabilities Act.
Both blatant and subtle discrimination
A young Al Gore
pushed for that law.
President Bush senior signed it.
Both parties applauded.
Who wouldn't?
Who could object
to a law that says
"No individual
with a disability
shall be
denied the benefits of services?
But as usual,
the good intentions had
unintended consequences.
All lectures are being deleted
so now no one can access them.
Berkeley took its videos down
because closed captioning is expensive.
It has to be done by a
person who listens
and then types out each word.
Computers can transcribe cheaply
but they're lousy at it.
When a Harvard video said
"on our campus",
it was transcribed as
"hot Kampen good".
Our experienced transcriptionists
will perfectly transcribe your recordings.
Berkeley didn't want to spend millions
on companies like this,
so it blocked everyone
from seeing its lectures.
Everyone's treated equally.
Hearing people
have no advantage over the deaf.
Nobody
gets to see the videos.
Government equality police
doing their work.
But
fortunately
the videos will survive,
thanks to the internet
and pissed off entrepreneurs
like Jeremy Kaufman.
We're gonna keep it available.
Kaufman downloaded
all the Berkeley videos before
they were taken down
and reposted them
to his web site
LBRY,
spelled funny.
The Justice Department might say
you're making life
tougher for deaf people.
I don't think anyone thinks that
it wouldn't be better
if stuff were subtitled for deaf people
but at the same time
it's ridiculous to say this content
can't be available unless
it's subtitled for deaf people.
Kaufman says he wants to help deaf people
but when closed captioning
costs millions,
Is that a reason that content
shouldn't be available to everyone?
Do you want to put a gun to someone's face
and say caption those videos?
It's absurd.
It is absurd.
But what government does
is often absurd.
Thank goodness for the internet
and people like Kaufman,
someone willing to spend his own money
to keep
information free.